Salut !
Dans la série 'mental tips'
où je vous débloque une compétence
dans votre cerveau,
à la fin de cette vidéo.
C'est à dire que
à la fin de la vidéo
vous savez faire
quelque chose de nouveau.
On va parler des rêves lucides.
Comme ça vous allez
apprendre à faire un rêve lucide.
Peut-être même ce soir.
Cette vidéo est sponsorisée
et approuvée par ExpressVPN.
Un VPN,  vous savez ce que c'est ?
Si vous ne savez pas,
renseignez vous.
Je plaisante !
Si vous savez pas, ça vous
permet de vous connecter
en faisant croire que vous
n'êtes pas à l'endroit où vous êtes.
En gros c'est comme, il y a un pont
et puis toi en fait t'es là
et tout le reste du monde
croit que tu es là,
parce que tu es connecté
à partir de là.
Voilà.
Mais utiliser les services
d'ExpressVPN
ça peut vous servir
à quoi concrètement ?
Imaginons, moi qui suis
beaucoup en tournée
je suis souvent dans les gares,
dans les aéroports, dans les hôtels,
dans des wifi publics.
Eh bien ça me permet de
me connecter à partir de mon VPN
pour sécuriser ma connexion.
Qui dit tournée, dit aussi voyage.
Donc quand je suis à l'étranger,
quand j'étais en Thaïlande
ou si je vais en Chine par exemple.
C'est intéressant d'avoir
un VPN pour se connecter
à tous ces services habituels
que l'on a en France.
Mais vous pouvez aussi
vous connecter
en faisant croire que vous êtes
en Allemagne par exemple.
Démonstration.
Pour le moment, je suis connecté
à l'ExpressVPN depuis Paris.
Mais maintenant, là d'un coup
de baguette magique, la Germany.
Et c'est bon je suis
à Francfort actuellement.
Vous ne saviez pas
que j'étais à Francfort ?
ça permet aussi pour certains
catalogues de streaming
comme Netflix, de se connecter
pour avoir accès aux catalogues
des autres pays.
Alors ça fonctionne dans la plupart
des cas, pas tout le temps.
Je peux pas vous dire
que ça fonctionne à 100%.
Ils utilisent Trust Server Technology
et ça ça compte pour moi.
Qu'est ce que ça veut dire ?
ça veut dire qu'il est impossible
pour leurs serveurs VPN
de sauvegarder les datas
de leurs clients.
Et ça a été auditée par Pwc.
ça j'apprécie particulièrement.
Vous avez toutes les infos
dans la description,
il y a 3 mois offerts pour vous
en passant par mon lien.
Donc n'hésitez pas, le lien
s'affiche également ici.
Merci ExpressVPN.
Alors j'avais déjà fait deux vidéos
sur les rêves lucides.
Mais le sujet méritait vraiment
une troisième vidéo,
une petite mise à jour
et puis dans l'absolu vous me suiviez
pas tous en 2016 quoi, tu vois.
- Ouais, moi non plus je ne
te suivais pas en 2016.
- Ah oui, t'as commencé à
me suivre quand d'ailleurs en vrai ?
- Suivre par rapport à ?
- Abonnement, abonné à la chaine.
- Ah, alors ça...
C'est marrant que t'en parles
parce que j'avais commencé...
- T'es pas abonné à la chaine,
à ma propre chaine ?
- Loïc, générique !
[Musique]
Comme toujours
dans cette série,
l'idée c'est de vous débloquer
une compétence dans le cerveau,
une fois que vous avez
regardé cette vidéo.
Sans qu'il n'y ait des travaux à faire
ou des choses a répéter,
un milliard de fois.
Pour ce qui est de
qu'est-ce qu'un rêve lucide
ou les pièges de rêve lucide.
Je vous laisse vous référer
aux deux autres vidéos
que j'avais fait précédemment.
Vous pourrez les regarder
à la suite de celle là,
je les mettrai en fin de vidéo
et dans la description.
Mais en gros
faire un rêve lucide,
c'est avoir conscience
que l'on rêve pendant le rêve.
C'est à dire pendant
qu'on est endormi,
on a conscience qu'on est
à l'intérieur d'un rêve.
Et depuis quelques années
il y a des chercheurs qui cherchent,
parce que c'est vraiment
le taff des chercheurs.
Comment on pourrait
provoquer le rêve lucide.
Alors il y a une étude
qui a été faite en 2014,
qui a démontré qu'avec
des stimulations électriques
qu'on envoyait directement
comme ça dans le cerveau des gens.
Eh bien 77% des dormeurs
avaient des éclairs de lucidité
quand ils recevaient
comme ça de l'électricité
pendant le sommeil paradoxal.
Heureusement, les rêves lucides
n'ont pas besoin de chimie
ou de chocs électriques
transcrâniens pour être provoqués.
On peut le faire naturellement.
Bah merci.
Et on le fait depuis
longtemps, très longtemps,
très, très, très longtemps.
Tellement longtemps
qu'on trouve même des traces
dans des tribus
en Amazonie ou ailleurs,
je veux pas dire de bêtises.
De gens qui pratiquent le rêve lucide
comme un art de vivre.
La première chose qui aide
à avoir de la lucidité onirique,
on appelle ça comme ça.
C'est de faire
une immersion dans le sujet,
de s'imprégner à fond du sujet et de
donner là dessus, de cet univers-là.
Et c'est pas mal,
parce que c'est exactement
ce que vous êtes en train
de faire avec cette vidéo.
Et ça ça va aider à provoquer
des rêves lucides chez vous.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que la nuit quand on dort,
il y a notre cerveau
qui traite un petit peu
toutes les informations
qu'il a vécu dans la journée.
Et donc comme ce sera frais
dans votre mémoire,
le cerveau et l'inconscient fera
plus facilement un rebond là dessus.
Mais comment s'imprégner ?
Donc en regardant cette vidéo,
en regardant les deux autres.
Ou peut-être même ce soir
avant de vous coucher
en regardant le film Inception,
qui traite de ce sujet là.
Quoi qu'il en soit, le déblocage
a déjà commencé.
L'intérêt d'un rêve lucide,
c'est le contrôle
et donc ce qu'on peut expérimenter
dans cet univers imaginaire
grâce à ce contrôle.
Mais ce contrôle, il est très
nuancé d'un rêve à l'autre.
C'est à dire qu'on peut
avoir le contrôle absolu.
En clair on est dieu.
On peut changer les décors,
on peut changer les lois de la physique,
on peut s'envoler,
on peut changer les gens,
on peut faire faire
les actions qu'on veut
aux gens qu'il y a
autour de nous.
ça c'est assez rare,
c'est vraiment le full contrôle.
C'est la plus haute des nuances.
Et la plus faible des nuances,
qui est d'ailleurs souvent
la plus courante.
On subit un scénario.
C'est à dire que on n'a pas
décidé des décors,
de ce qui se passe exactement,
de l'intrigue de l'action,
parce que dans le rêve,
il y a toujours un conflit qu'on est
en train de résoudre quel qu'il soit.
Donc on n'a pas décidé de ça.
Et par contre on a conscience
d'être dans un rêve
et on a notre liberté de penser
et de mouvement dans ce rêve.
Et on agit avec ça au mieux.
Ce que vous devez
savoir et comprendre
là en écoutant bien la vidéo pour
que ça continue de débloquer,
c'est trois choses.
La première chose
c'est qu'un rêve lucide
ça dure pas forcément longtemps
et que le contrôle qu'on a dessus
n'est pas forcément permanent.
C'est à dire on peut très bien
passer d'une phase de rêve.
A rêve lucide avec
tous les pouvoirs.
Puis tout de suite après,
à rêve lucide avec pas de pouvoir,
scénario imposé.
Puis après à rêve normal.
Puis rerêve lucide,
ça c'est très rare.
En général un rêve lucide
est entouré de deux rêves normaux.
C'est à dire,
à la fin d'un rêve lucide,
on repart dans un rêve normal
et on perd la lucidité.
Mais vous voyez il n'y a pas
de règle vis-à-vis de ça, quoi.
Des fois quand on parle avec quelqu'un
qui a jamais fait un rêve lucide,
il fantasme sur le fait
que ce soit un rêve de dingue.
Et qu'on a tous les pouvoirs
toujours dedans.
C'est pas si simple.
ça m'amène au point 2.
Un rêve lucide, c'est pas forcément
un rêve de ouf.
C'est toujours une expérience
incroyable à vivre,
le fait d'être lucide
pendant un rêve.
ça c'est dingue.
Mais le rêve en lui-même
n'est pas forcément dingue,
surtout quand c'est un scénario
imposé par notre inconscient.
Il y a des rêves qui sont
plus marquant que d'autres.
Pour pleins de raisons,
par rapport à ce qui s'y passe.
Moi, l'autre jour je rêvais
que je pilotais un avion.
Forcément le rêve il était
un petit peu fou, tu vois.
C'est pas parce qu'on fait
un rêve lucide que
c'est un rêve qui sera
incroyable a raconter.
Pas nécessairement.
Par contre,
c'est chouette à vivre.
Et la troisième chose qui va
le plus nous intéresser là.
C'est qu'on peut
oublier un rêve lucide.
Il y a une idée reçue
qui dit qu'un rêve lucide,
on va s'en rappeler parce qu'on
était conscient pendant le rêve.
Non, pas du tout.
Pas nécessairement.
Il subit le même
traitement que les rêves.
ça veut dire qu'à votre réveil,
vous pouvez oublier d'avoir
fait un rêve lucide
ou avoir le vague souvenir
d'avoir fait un rêve lucide
et de plus vous
en souvenir du tout après.
Il suffit parfois que
vous ayez eu un réveil,
un vrai réveil durant la nuit.
Et de vous rendormir pour que le
lendemain ce souvenir du rêve lucide,
il soit complètement effacé.
Et c'est bien ça le problème.
On rêve tous et toutes
chaque nuit.
Même toi qui peut-être
pense ne pas rêver, tu rêves.
Sauf problème particulier,
on rêve tous la nuit.
Sauf que c'est difficile
de se souvenir de ses rêves.
Encore plus à l'époque
à laquelle on vit,
où on a des réveils,
on se réveille plus naturellement.
On se réveille en mettant
un réveil le matin.
Souvent on a un très
mauvais réflexe,
à peine on se réveille et on prend
le téléphone dans les mains
et on passe à autre chose.
Et le cerveau, il est fait pour
évacuer le rêve de la nuit.
Il est fait pour évacuer
ce souvenir là,
pour pas qu'on le confonde
avec la réalité.
Ou pour pas que plus tard,
on confonde le souvenir du rêve
avec le souvenir de quelque chose
qui se soit déjà passé.
Il faut donc que vous domptiez
votre mémoire onirique.
Et là aussi, vous avez
beaucoup de chance.
C'est extrêmement
simple à faire.
En gros, il y a trois choses.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'apparemment,
il y a toujours trois choses.
La première chose, elle est
simple, claire et logique.
Elle va vous changer la vie
d'une manière générale.
Ne vous jetez pas sur votre téléphone
quand vous vous réveillez.
C'est une mauvaise habitude,
il faut s'en débarrasser.
Moi je l'ai eu aussi
pendant un temps.
Je m'en suis débarrassé
il y a quelques années.
Quand vous vous réveillez,
retrouvez vous vous-même,
prenez le temps de vous réveiller,
de penser, de vous lever,
de prendre votre petit déjeuner,
de vous laver.
Et ensuite seulement,
vous prendrez votre téléphone.
Donc n'allez pas directement
capter de nouvelles informations,
parce que ça va encore plus
vous déconnecter de vos rêves.
En deux, du coup comme
quand vous vous réveillez,
vous ne vous jetez plus
sur le téléphone.
Eh bien gardez un petit peu
les yeux fermés
et essayez de vous rappeler
un peu mieux de vos rêves.
Parce qu'ils sont encore présents,
ils sont pas très loin en fait.
Donc vous pouvez retirer,
un peu comme le fil
d'une pelote de laine.
Vous avez un petit souvenir,
"Attends, je rêvais de ça,
c'était quoi ?"
Et vous tirez
là dessus mentalement
et vous allez retrouver
un peu l'intégralité du rêve,
refaites vous un petit peu le rêve
et un maximum d'informations.
Alors, sachez que les rêves
sont incohérents, ils sont décousus.
ça passe d'une scène à l'autre,
ça n'a aucun rapport.
Mais quand on est dans le rêve,
ça nous paraît logique.
Donc quand vous allez chercher
à bien vous rappeler de votre rêve,
évidemment ça donne
une histoire déconstruite,
mais c'est pas grave.
Rappelez-vous
des différentes scènes,
que vous avez
un petit peu en flash
et vous allez essayer de vous
les remémorer comme ça.
Ce qui nous amène
à la troisième chose.
Une fois que vous avez
ces souvenirs en tête.
Vous notez ça dans un carnet
ou exceptionnellement
dans l'application de
votre téléphonede votre choix.
Fin l'application de votre choix,
dans votre téléphone
de votre choix aussi, parce que...
- Oui parce que le téléphone
de ton choix...
- Ici on impose rien !
- Le matin...
On a un IPhone,
un Samsung, un Huawei...
Qu'est ce que c'est, t'habites dans
une fabrique de téléphone ou quoi ?
- je n'ai pas de contre-vanne.
Mais vraiment notez le.
Alors le plus simple à faire,
moi c'est ce que je faisais aussi,
quand j'essayais de dompter
ma mémoire onirique,
c'est d'avoir un carnet et un stylo
juste à côté du lit.
Comme ça vous vous réveillez
vous notez.
Alors au départ, moi je notais
quelques mots en me disant :
"Comme ça ça me
rappellera le rêve".
Que nenni.
Notez bien des phrases entières,
parce que le temps passe.
Et ce souvenir...
Il descend au plus profond
de votre mémoire.
Donc ayez des phrases entières,
décrivez le décor,
les sensations que vous aviez,
ce genre de choses.
On est déjà à la troisième partie
de cette vidéo.
Donc à la troisième étape
du déblocage,
qui va faire que vous allez faire
un rêve lucide prochainement.
Peut-être même ce soir.
Pour ce déclenchement,
il nous faut exactement...
- Trois choses, je suppose
puisque avec toi c'est toujours :
"Eh il faut trois choses
pour déclencher...".
- Alors, il faut effectivement
trois choses.
- Ouais.
- Mais c'est pas qu'avec moi Loïc.
C'est dans la vie,
d'une manière générale,
souvent il faut trois choses.
- Ah ouais, vas-y, cite moi 3 choses
qu'il faut dans la vie comme ça ?
- Riri, Fifi et loulou.
Il faut boire, manger et dormir.
Ou boire manger, dormir
et respirer pour vivre.
Et pour être heureux il faut...
- Il m'en faut très peu.
- Avoir une vie
personnelle épanouie,
une vie professionnelle
épanouie et des...
- Quoi ?
Okay, le mec pète un câble.
Je crois que tu ne sais pas
ce que ça veut dire Fabien.
- 1, vous allez devoir graver
le message dans votre inconscient.
Le message que vous voulez
faire un rêve lucide.
ça va vous aider en fait,
à prendre conscience
que vous rêvez quand
vous êtes en train rêver.
En gros, avant de
vous coucher, ce soir.
Quand vous sentez que
vous vous endormez.
Donc non, vous êtes déjà couché.
Mais juste avant
de vous endormir,
vous dites en chuchotant
une phrase du type :
"La prochaine fois que je vais rêver
j'aurais conscience que je rêve".
Voilà, vous allez prononcer
une phrase comme ça.
Parce que ça envoie quelque chose
de très clair à votre cerveau,
que vous êtes
dans cette démarche là.
Et ça laisse
une trace très forte.
Alors, il y a une nouvelle technique
qui est apparue ces dernières années.
Qui n'est pas bête du tout.
C'est que si vous avez
votre réveil matin
qui est mis à 8 heures,
par exemple.
Alors vous mettez le réveil
un peu plus d'une heure avant.
7h ou 6h50.
Enfin vous gardez
l'autre réveil également.
Vous en rajoutez un
1h-1h10 avant.
Et quand le réveil sonne,
vous l'éteignez.
Vous n'ouvrez pas les yeux,
vous dites la phrase,
vous la reprononcez.
"La prochaine fois que je vais rêver,
je veux avoir conscience que je rêve".
Et vous allez vous rendormir
tout de suite,
beaucoup plus instantanément
que le soir avant de vous coucher.
Et ça va favoriser
encore une fois la lucidité.
En 2, vous allez devoir
enclencher un test de réalité.
Alors ça c'est hyper important.
C'est à dire que quand
vous dormez,
votre esprit critique,
il dort complètement lui aussi.
Les rêves, c'est n'importe quoi.
Vous êtes dans un avion,
vous ouvrez une porte,
vous êtes dans votre cuisine,
en train de faire des pâtes.
Et vous parlez à quelqu'un et
cette personne change de visage,
puis elle change de nom
et ça change de lieu.
Et vraiment tout est normal.
ça t'es arrivé des trucs
comme ça ou pas Loïc ?
- Je ne rêve pas Fabien.
- Okay.
- Je suis très terre à terre...
- Si vous avez un test de réalité,
que vous faites régulièrement
dans la vie normale,
dans la réalité évidemment.
ça va devenir un petit peu
un toc, une habitude
que vous allez reproduire
malgré vous, durant vos rêves.
Sauf que durant le rêve, ce test
de réalité ne va pas fonctionner
et là vous allez en avoir conscience
que vous êtes en train de rêver.
ça va être une excitation
un peu particulière à vivre.
On va en reparler après.
Alors d'habitude, chacun
a son propre test de réalité,
mais là comme
le concept de la vidéo,
c'est de vous débloquer
une compétence maintenant.
On va avoir le même test
de réalité ensemble, maintenant.
Faites le.
S'il vous plaît, faites le.
Même toi Loïc, tu peux
essayer de le faire.
- Bien sûr !
vous allez tous
pincer votre nez.
- Ouais.
- Mettre la main
devant notre bouche.
Et vous essayez de respirer.
Non, non, non, sans ouvrir la bouche
et sans dépincer le nez.
Est-ce que tu arrives
à respirer Loïc ?
Est-ce que vous arrivez à respirer ?
Non, la réponse est non.
Respirez maintenant,
respirez vite.
Donc vous n'arrivez pas à respirer.
Donc le test de réalité
c'est vraiment,
on pince son nez et on voit
si on arrive à respirer.
La réponse est non,
sauf que quand
vous allez essayer de faire ça
par automatisme dans un rêve,
vous allez réussir à respirer.
ça va réactiver un peu
votre esprit critique qui va se dire :
"Waouh, il se passe quelque chose
je crois que je suis dans un rêve".
Et enfin de la troisième chose,
c'est quand vous êtes
dans votre lit le soir
et que vous imaginez
un peu des scénarios,
des choses comme ça,
vous êtes en train de
rêvasser comme on dit.
Essayez de vous forcer
à vous voir vous,
à la première personne.
C'est à dire que vraiment,
si vous rêvez de vous même,
si vous rêvassez de vous même,
du moins avant
de vous endormir vraiment.
Imaginez les yeux fermés que
vous voyez vos bras devant vous.
Que vous voyez pourquoi pas
le flou de l'arête du nez qu'on voit ici.
Habituez vous à ça,
parce que quand on rêve
et qu'on veut faire un rêve lucide.
Le rêve lucide ne fonctionne pas
à ma connaissance,
quand on rêve
comme s'il y avait...
On avait un regard caméra et on se
voyait en fait à la troisième personne.
On se voyait déporté.
Moi, malheureusement,
je rêve souvent comme ça.
Ce qui m'empêche parfois
de faire des rêves lucides,
donc il faut s'habituer à s'imaginer
soi même dans son propre corps,
voyant par son propre regard.
Tu rêves comment toi là ?
A la troisième personne plutôt
ou avec tes yeux ?
- Moi, la deuxième personne.
- La deuxième personne, c'est
quelqu'un d'autre qui rêve pour toi.
- Je t'ai dis, je suis très terre à terre.
D'ailleurs, je vous disais
tout à l'heure,
la première fois
qu'on fait un rêve lucide
et même souvent
les autres fois.
Au moment où l'on perçoit qu'on
est en train de faire un rêve lucide.
On a une excitation,
le cœur qui s'accélère
et on peut se réveiller
à cause de ça.
Il y a un truc qui marche pas mal,
c'est de se créer un personnage fictif,
une espèce de projection mentale,
qui apparaît dans ces moments là.
Alors là pour la faire exister
cette projection, c'est très simple.
Vous fermez les yeux dans votre lit
avant de vous coucher.
Et vous imaginez en fait
ce qui pourrait se passer,
qui pourrait être cette personne,
ce qu'elle pourrait vous dire.
"Calme toi, t'es dans un rêve lucide".
Comme si vous pensiez à un ami
imaginaire ou un truc comme ça.
Imaginez cette personne la,
fantasmez la.
Pas de fantasmes chelous,
parce que j'allais vous dire,
vous pouvez imaginer
que c'est moi.
Mais vraiment vous pouvez créer
un avatar de moi même,
une projection mentale.
Et vous dire :
"Ben tiens quand je ferai
un rêve lucide, ce qui serait bien
c'est que ça va me rappeler
la vidéo de Fabien
et que Fabien arrive vers moi
en disant attends calme-toi,
tout va bien, c'est un rêve lucide
tu es dans ton rêve,
tu fais ce que tu veux".
Même le fait de vous expliquer ça,
là maintenant ça va favoriser
la création de cette projection
mentale et de cet avatar.
Et peut-être vous allez du coup
me voir apparaître sur un rêve lucide.
Si c'est le cas, vraiment vous
me le dites dans les commentaires
ce sera assez cool
d'avoir vos retours là dessus.
Parce que oui, voilà !
Vous êtes enfin prêts à faire
votre premier rêve lucide
ou peut-être à refaire un rêve lucide
cette nuit ou dans celles qui viennent.
Si c'est le cas
vraiment vous venez
vous nous dites ça
dans les commentaires,
vous partagez votre expérience.
Racontez-nous le rêve,
ça va être très cool
de créer un espace comme ça.
Petit récap des points essentiels
pour bien débloquer cette compétence.
Vous imprégner un maximum
des rêves lucides,
donc regardez ma vidéo
ou les anciennes.
Regardez le film Inception,
parlez rêves lucides avec des gens
que vous connaissez.
Donc voilà,
s'imprégner un max de ça.
Deuxième chose,
faire des tests de réalité
assez souvent dans votre vie normale.
Tenez ça, continuez à faire ça
de jour en jour.
Troisième chose, notez vos rêves
quand vous vous réveillez,
c'est très important de faire ça.
Et la quatrième,
tout aussi importante,
formulez la phrase
avant de vous endormir.
- Je croyais qu'il y avait que
trois à chaque fois Fabien.
Bah là j'ai pas dis 4.
J'ai juste énuméré.
Tu sais, il y trois choses
qui me gonflent chez toi.
Et pour pas vous
créer d'impatience,
sachez qu'un bon
rêveur lucide comme on dit.
Quelqu'un qui est habitué à en faire,
il en fait rarement plus de 5 par mois.
Donc ne soyez pas déçus
de ne pas en faire un chaque nuit.
Je pirate moi-même ma propre vidéo
juste pour remercier avant la fin,
ExpressVPN d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo.
Je vous rappelle que si
ExpressVPN vous intéresse,
vous avez un lien
dans la description
qui vous explique comment avoir
les 3 mois gratuits dès le départ.
Voilà merci à eux.
Voilà un nouveau savoir
de téléchargé dans votre cerveau,
une nouvelle compétence
de débloquée.
Je vous recommande
d'enchaîner avec cette vidéo,
qui était la première
sur les rêves lucides
ou celle ci où je parle
des pièges sur les rêves lucides.
Si vous débarquez,
je m'appelle Fabien Olicard.
Abonnez-vous à cette
chaîne YouTube, c'est gratuit.
Activez la cloche pour
ne pas rater la prochaine vidéo
qui va vous intéresser,
j'en suis sûr.
Et moi je vous dis à très vite ici
ou sur mon Instagram.
A très bientôt,
Ciao !